[Music]
I am Mike Saemaul from FX guide.com for
wired looking at the character visual
effects in the final episodes of HBO's
Game of Thrones in the end of series 4
fans of the show were rewarded with some
really impressive fights such as the
major battle of the war between the free
folk north of the war and the men of
Night's Watch
it was an excellent chance to see also
the range of character work done by the
visual effects teams if you recall we
actually looked before at the visual
effects of Game of Thrones the dragon
characters of course in series for the
dragons are bigger so gone are those
stuffed toy referenced and ends of
previous series now Emilia Clarke is
filmed reacting to full-sized molded
plastic heads on sticks which Pixar
mando then replaced with the detailed CG
dragons also advanced from earlier
seasons are the implementations of the
whites the reanimated undead of the
White Walkers as bran stark and his
companions reach the cave of the
three-eyed Ravens they are attacked by a
group of whites that emerge from the
snow-covered ground mirror fights them
off by actually fighting a healthy
stuntman in a green suit for the shoot
which lasted four or five days in the
brutal weather outside Belfast the
production actually asked for the
thinnest stuntman that casting could
find they then matched CG characters
over the top of the motion of these
filmed green-screen stuntmen the whites
couldn't actually be matched perfectly
to these stuntmen not only because of
their skeletal form but also because the
team at scanline VFX wanted a sense of
rigor mortis a stiffness added in
because those whites had actually been
dead and buried in the snow for some
time but the series are also saw some
new characters such as at the wall the
massive 700 foot high wall that
stretches from forestry mountains in the
West the bay of seals in the east the
wall is attacked by the free folk or the
wildlings army now complete with Giants
and woolly mammoths these shots required
some creative thinking the team at MPC
had to animate completely those mammoth
walk cycles before anything else so the
team could then program the motion basis
that the giant sat on to move correctly
allowing the
actors playing the Giants to be
composited back on the walking CG
mammoths and still move and sway
correctly now this was made even more
complicated by the fact that the Giants
had to be shot with a special scaled
motion control green-screen system this
would allow the Giants to be scaled up
relative to the normal actors who are
playing the wildlings of the north that
are moving next to them and they all had
to move a correctly in perspective
throughout the shot if you scale an
element then you have to reduce all of
its angles and tilts the compensate NPC
who produced all the attack shots and
use their fertility tool for the mammoth
fur also produced the massive scythe
shot which dispatches the climbing
wildlings on the wall here the
characters are actually live-action and
the environment and all the effects are
added as CG showing that sometimes the
best solution to character work is to
actually use real actors whenever
possible and then just add and craft the
final shots by adding in complex CG and
effects simulation animation well don't
forget subscribe for more behind the
scenes action i'm mike seymour for wide
[Music]